et notre invité ce matin c'est Jérôme
Fourquet merci Jérôme forquet d'être
avec nous bonjour politologue directeur
du département Opinion alifop et auteur
de ce livre la France d'après c'est aux
édition du seuil et on va bien sûr
longuement en parler d'abord on va
commencer parce qu'on a envie évidemment
d'avoir votre regard je le disais en
introduction vous êtes un vous avez
étudié de prè c'est factures françaises
la sociologie électorale du pays et ce
qui se passe dans notre société et sur
ce qui s'est passé à crépole il y a une
quinzaine de jours et ce meurtre du
jeune Thomas lycéen de 16 ans au cours
d'un bal de village est-ce que pour vous
c'est un fait divers ou un fait de
société alors c'est un c'est un fait
divers mais qui prend une résonance
particulière dans ce sens où euh il
présente un certain nombre de
caractéristiques emblématiques d'une
part et d'autre part dans la mesure où
nous sommes face à un phénomène de
réitération c'est-à-dire que des
attaques au
couteau visant de de très jeunes
personnes et bien se se multiplie dans
notre pays vous connaissez la différence
entre le fait divivers et le fait de
société c'est quand il y a plusieurs
faits divers ça devient un fait de
société donc on est dans cette on est
dans cette logique là et on voit
l'émotion très vive que cette affaire a
a suscité partout dans le pays et 15
jours plus tard euh nous commentons
encore donc il faut prendre toute la
mesure du du traumatisme qu'a créé cette
cette affaire qui encore une fois mêle
un certain nombre d'ingrédients
emblématiques est-ce qu'on est dans dans
l'illustration des deux France côte à
côte voir face à face dont parlait
Gérard Colomb alors on on on on a quand
même ce ce sentiment là quand on regarde
les choses on a d'un côté la France de
Crépol la France des villages la France
du rugby la France de ce jeune garçon
dont les parents étaient c'est
restaurateurs euh et quelque part si on
reste dans l'univers du rugby on
pourrait se dire que c'est la France de
jeanmiche celle qui avait été mise en
scène par Jean Dujardin lors de la
cérémonie d'ouverture des de la Coupe du
monde du rugby et de l'autre on a ces
jeunes qui sont venus euh dans ce dans
ce bal qui venait de la cité de la
monnaie et qui représente quelque part
cette cette France des quartiers et
c'est cette cette confrontation qui a eu
lieu de manière tout à fait dramatique
Éric dupomoretti pour décrire ces de
France il accuse le RN d'opposer je le
cite la France rurale est tranquille
catholique et blanche à la France des
cités la France des Mohammed des Mouloud
et des Rachid vous les décrirez comme ça
vous ces deux Frances alors c'est pas là
c'est très
caricatural il y a beaucoup de de
nuances à apporter d'abord sur cette
cette France des cités il faut il faut
avoir en tête que la la cité de la
monnaie c'est 4500 habitants et de la
veœu ou de la vie de la maire de la
commune et des des services de police on
a quelques dizaines de jeunes 50 80 100
qui sont très profondément engagés dans
dans la l'action
délinquante qui cause des troubles et
des dégâts et des nuisances
considérables et parfois qui peuvent
aller jusqu'au jusqu'au meurtre mais
c'est pas tous les habitants de de ce
quartier toute une partie des habitants
de ce quartier de la monnaie sont elles
aussi victimes euh de ces de ces bandes
délinquantes euh là où le le problème
est compliqué c'est que ces effectifs
délinquants se régénère progressivement
voyez si vous faites l'histoire du du
quartier de la monnaie en 2008 puis en
2015 on a eu deux affaair de voitures
volées avec course poursuite de la
police qui se sont soldé par des
accidents et le décès de très jeunes
conducteurs 14 et 15 ans qui portaient
les mêmes prénoms le même type de prénom
que ceux qui sont cités dans dans la
affire de crépool et c'était déjà 2008
c'était déjà il y a 15 ans et donc voyez
que
euh régulièrement de nouvelles bandes
euh juvénil délinquant se apparaissent
se structur autour du trafic de drogue
et cause toute une série de de
désagréments donc attention à
l'opposition entre ces ces deux
populations c'est des il y a des noyaux
délinquants qui euh qu'il ne faut pas
assimiler à l'ensemble de la population
locale dans votre livre vous étudiez
bien sûr la la sociologie électorale
hein c'est c'est votre spécialité est-ce
que pour ramener ça à un électorat vous
diriez qu'on est dans une France rurale
représentée par le rassemblement
national face à une France des banlieux
plutôt représentée par la France
insoumise une sorte de crépolisation
contre créolisation alors là encore
attention au au raccourci quand on
regarde les résultats du premier tour à
crépool cert Marine Le Pen fait près de
30 % des voix donc nettement au-dessus
de sa moyenne nationale mais c'est 30 %
c'est c'estàd qu'il y a des des
électeurs qui ont voté Mélenchon qui ont
voté Macron qui ont voté Zemour et
cetera et cetera donc il y a une
tendance qui est claire mais qui est
loin d'être massive et donc il y a une
grande diversité y compris électorale
dans ces territoires en revanche
effectivement dans des quartiers comme
ceux de la monnaie on est plutôt sur un
un vote Mélenchon à 50 voire 60 % donc
c'est plus typé d'un côté que de l'autre
en fonction de ça bien évidemment
également chaque euh
figure politique va tenir un discours
singulier qui correspond certes à ses
convictions mais qui qui entend aussi
s'ancré dans une population et parler à
certains territoires ou à certains
groupes sociologiques chacun quelque
part adopte la grille de lecture de son
électorat et on va on va y revenir sur
ces deux électorats puisque vous les
avez analysé dans votre livre juste pour
finir sur cette affaire de crpol on a vu
dans les jours qui ont suivi des sortes
d'expéditions punitives qui ont été
menées par des des grosuscules d'ultra
droite est-ce que c'est cette volonté de
représaille elle reste cantonnée à ce
type de mouvement d'ultra droite ou
est-ce que demain les citoyens lambda
vont vouloir se faire justice même alors
c'est une grande crainte justifier des
des pouvoirs publics c'est-à-dire que la
loi de la République
soit abandonné au profit de celle du
talion et que des groupes au nom de la
logique de l'honneur de la logique de la
vengeance se fasse justice même euh fort
heureusement ce type de comportement est
très très euh marginal en France on l'a
vu quelquefois en Corse hein ou suite à
des des affaires une partie de la
population locale est descendue comme on
dit euh dans le quartier incriminé pour
euh faire justice soi même mais on est
en Corse euh on a euh ce on a des des
phénomènes parfois de ce type entre des
bandes euh communautaires des des gitan
contre euh des des Maghrébins par
exemple on a v eu l'affaire des
tchenenses et des Maghrébins à Dijon
mais on est sur des phénomènes qui sont
très euh très marginaux euh ce qui s'est
passé à Roman effectivement vous l'avez
dit c'est une mobilisation de
groupuscule d'extrême droite ou d'ultra
droite 80 à 100 individus donc c'est pas
euh négligeable c'est pas non plus
l'énorme mobilisation le profil des
jeunes qui ont été interpellés montre
qu'ils venaient de toute la France et
donc c'est pas c'est absolument pas euh
une partie de la population de crépool
ou des villages environnants de roman
qui se serait euh euh mobilisé pour
aller dans ce dans ce quartier donc il
faut faire la part des choses ne pas
minimiser la gravité euh de l'initiative
de ces groupuscules la police est
interpellée mais on ne sait pas ce qui
se serait passé si la police n'avait pas
été là et on rappelle que cette mouvance
d'ultr droite même si elle ne grossit
pas en effectif c'est à peu près 3000
individus dont la moitié sont fich s euh
a présenter un certain nombre de menaces
c'est euh il y a 20 ans maintenant plus
de 20 ans maintenant un jeune de ce de
cette mouvance là Maxime Brunery qui
avait attenté à la vie de de Jacques
Chirac lors du défilé du 14 juillet il y
avait déjà eu il y a déjà eu ces
dernières années des des tentatives
d'attentat de la part de cette mouvance
mais on est sur quelques milliers
d'individus on n'est pas vers on n'est
pas vers un risque de scénario de guerre
civile que la pointé Gérald on n'est pas
là-dedans euh néanmoins si comme on l'a
dit fort heureusement c'est pas la loi
du talon qui aujourd'hui est appliqué en
France c'est parce que les citoyens font
encore confiance à la République à la sa
police et sa justice et il faut que sur
l'affaire de crépool et bien la justice
passe de manière implacable sans quoi ce
risque euh de de débordement pourrait
peut-être demain se se développer quelle
conséquence dans les urnes de ce ce type
de fait est-ce que c'est forcément une
augmentation du vote à rassemement
national alors c'est pas aussi mécanique
que cela et euh encore une fois à juste
titre euh nous le pays entier a été
saisi par ce qui s'était passé à à
Crépol mais hélas ce n'est pas la la
première fois il y a quelques temps on
avait eu aussi une très forte émotion à
Bayonne avec un chauffeur de bus
monsieur Montillot qui avait été qui
avait été poignardé pour une affaire de
masque qui était mal porté pendant la la
crise sanitaire on a eu l'affaire de la
petite Lola euh en dans l'Est dans l'est
parisien et donc une des tèses que je
défends dans le livre c'est cette notion
de bruit de fond c'està-dire
l'accumulation de ce type d'affaire
médiatisé ou non qui petit à petit
infuse dans dans l'opinion et donc vous
avez pas un point de bascule entre un
avant et un après crpol c'est un espèce
de continuum qui se déploie sur
maintenant une vingtaine d'années et qui
explique de mon point de vue en partie
il y a pas que ça comme explication mais
que quand Jean-Marie Le Pen était face à
Chirac à Jacques Chirac en 2002 le score
de Jean-Marie Le Pen avait été de 18 %
des voix et que l'année dernière sa
fille face à Emmanuel Macron a fait 41 5
% des voix ce que j'appelle la montée
des eau bleu marines dont un des
carburants est ce type de d'affaire de
fait divers qui aliment ce bruit de fond
alors justement dans votre livre vous
analysez électoralement ces deux Frances
d'aujourd'hui la France Macron contre la
France Le Pen c'est un peu la France
d'en haut contre la France d'en bas
alors on le voit c'est en partie ça on
le voit
sociologiquement vote des cadres des
professions les plus diplômé
préférentiellement pour Emmanuel Macron
ou BR employé pour
euh Marine Le Pen Marine Le Pen vous
parlez des différences selon le niveau
de le métier exercé et le niveau de
diplôme rappelons d'ailleurs le niveau
de diplôme des cadres du rassemblement
national et et alors effectivement une
variable de plus en plus structurante on
le voit nous dans nos études c'est le
niveau de diplôme et on constate une
certaine homologie entre le profil des
cadres du Ren qui sont en moyenne moins
diplômés que ceux de leur des autres
formations politiques qui ont fait des
études plus courte et qui comme ça sont
en espèce de d'osmose avec leurs
électeurs si on poursuit sur France d'en
haut France d'en bas toujours
sociologiquement on avait posé une
question qui était plus celle du métier
ou du diplôme mais qui portait sur le
degré de pénibilité ouais du métier on
voyait que plus le métier était ressenti
comme comme pénible plus le vote pour le
RN ou la France insoumise était
important et inversement moins le vote
Emmanuel Macron l'était donc on a une
France des managers de ceux qui euh
donnent
la direction donne les consignes et il y
a une une France qui exécute une France
qui applique qui voilà donc c'est un peu
caricaturel géographiquement retrouve le
même distingo avec une France du cœur
des métropoles une France des zones
touristiques qui va voter
préférentiellement pour Emmanuel Macron
que vous appelez la France triple afin
la France triple A la France
instagrammable effectivement et puis une
une France des périphéries une France un
peu plus de l'ombre une France des
rond-points une France des zones
périurbaines des anthropologistiques une
une France qui n'a pas vu sur mer une
France des fonds de vallée versus les
stations de ski qui elle va plutôt voter
pour Marine Le Pen à chaque fois disons
plutôt voter c'estàd c'est des tendances
parce que bien évidemment c'est jamais
massif et totalement homogène les
comportements électorauuxx sur Marine Le
Pen on a vu évidemment la 88 députés on
a vu sa présence autour d'Emmanuel
Macron comme les autres chefs chefs de
parti dans les rencontre de Saint-
c'était Jordan Bardella qui était leur
présence dans la marche contre
l'antisémitisme est-ce que la
dédiabolisation est complètement achevée
aujourd'hui alors
euh
l'institutionnalisation a beaucoup
progressé du fait du du succès de du RN
au au législatif avec ses 88 députés on
a parlé de la stratégie de la cravate
hein pour se
respectabilisé c'est ce qui manquait en
partie orn et vous avez tout à fait
raison de rappeler un fait qui pour le
coup est historique c'est la présence
d'une délégation importante du RN dans
la fameuse marche contre l'antisémitisme
et pour la défense de la République et
donc là c'est pour moi un symptôme
supplémentaire de l'entrée dans cette
France d'après qui est très différente
de cette France d'avant quand on
rappelle le précédent historique la
grande marche contre l'antisémitisme au
lendemain de la profanation du cimetière
juif de de carpanra où Jean-Marie Le Pen
et le Front national faisaient figure de
paria était personna non grata et et et
plus que cela la manifestation était
explicitement dirigée contre eux he le
slogan c'était LE PEN les mots
carpentrass les larmes c'était il y a 30
ans 30 ans plus tard la fille de
Jean-Marie Le Pen a droit de cité dans
une manif contre l'antisémitisme et pour
la défense de la République et ça montre
bien comment la tectonique des plaques a
évolué en une génération sur la France
Macron électoralement est-ce que le
macronisme c'est aussi le basculement
d'un électorat de droite de l'électorat
droite vers Emmanuel Macron alors oui en
en grande partie là aussi autre
illustration de cette euh bascule dans
une France d'après nous avons des
mouvements électoraux qui sont beaucoup
plus brutaux et euh des électorats qui
sont moins figés que par le le passé le
macronisme a surgi en 2017 Emmanuel
Macron était réélu en 2022 donc sacré
tour de force mais ce tour de force euh
a été obtenu au prix d'une
transformation très profonde de la
structure de l'électorat macronist
c'est-à-dire que toute une partie de
l'électorat centre-gauche qui l'avait
soutenu précocement en 2017 là abandonné
et ces pertes ont été plus que compensé
par l'apport d'un électorat de droite ça
se voit très clairement typiquement dans
les quartiers ou les arrondissements de
l'Ouest parisien ou toute une partie des
des des territoires de droite
traditionnel dans les zones de vignoble
ou autres où on passe de d'un vote de
droite un vote Macron ce qui fait dire
qu'on a eu un changement de groupe
sanguin du du macronisme ce qui là
encore est une illustration du fait que
tout ça est beaucoup plus fluide gazux
que par le passé que toutes les
structures d'ancrage traditionnel ont
quelque part été dynamité et justement
dans votre livre vous parlez vous
consacré un chapitre R et au PS est-ce
que le macronisme a acté la fin de ces
partis qui sont aujourd'hui ou qui prend
réduit au parti d'élus locaux alors on
on verra ce qu'il en il en sera demain
mais on est un peu quand même dans une
situation qu'on pourrait comparer à
celle de des tours jumelles après le les
attentats du du 11 septembre c'est gr
zero en fait pour le le pour pour les
nos téléspectateurs rappelons quand même
que le score au premier tour Dani dalgo
et Valérie PCR les deux représentants
des deux grands partis historiques c'est
6,4 % des voix Jean Lassal à lui tout
seul il fait 3 % des voix ERC Zemour
fait 7 % des voix dans 5700 communes
anidalgo est sous la barre des 0,5 %
donc il y a eu un dynamitage en règle un
effondrement de ces deux grands partis
alors comme souvent la dislocation de
vieille matrice ne se fait pas d'un seul
bloc ça se fait en étape et il reste
effectivement un trésor ou un actif
comme on dirait dans le milieu bancaire
tout à fait précieux pour ces partis
lreps c'est leur tissu leur maillage des
lots locaux qui sont encore très très
nombreux mais leur présence et leur
poids sur la scène politique nationale a
été très
fortement réduite du fait de la montée
en puissance de ce de ce bloc central
nous verrons si en saison 3 après 2017
et 2022 les choses évolue est-ce que
c'est pas forcément la fin du clivage
droite gauche pour vous aujourd'hui
alors moi je pense que le clivage
gauche- droite continue d'avoir du sens
mais la grande nouveauté c'est qu'il est
plus le clivage central auquel autour
duquel tout va seorganiser et donc les
deux parties qui l'incarnaient et bien
mécaniquement sont ravalés si vous
voulez en 2è division à partir du moment
où ce n'est plus le clivage qui est
gauche droite qui est le clivage premier
les parties qui l'incarnent sont
rétrogradé c'est aujourd'hui un autre
clivage qui se qui s'est imposé mais
est-ce que du coup pardon ça conduit à
l'émergence des extrêmes qui deviennent
aujourd'hui les forces d'alternance
alors les de bah on voit que ces deux
extrêmes se portent plutôt bien et la
grande question c'est de savoir est-ce
que le bloc central va perdurer et
survivre à au retrait de la scène
politique constitution oblige du ciment
et de l'architecte de ce bloc central
qui est Emmanuel Macron c'està-dire que
le macronisme pourrait ne pas survivre à
Emmanuel Macron ben posé comme ça vous
voyez il y a le le gaulisme a survi
quelques temps à général de Gaulle mais
tout le monde n'est pas de Gaulle et
donc il faut regarder ce qui va se
passer euh on voit déjà les écuries
personnelles se mettre en place pour
revendiquer chacune l'héritage putatif
du du macronisme c'est c'est c'est d'un
grand classique euh et donc ces fortes
centrifuges on les voit bien il y a
néanmoins quelques forces de de cohésion
de ce bloc central d'abord il y a une
idéologie par partagé autour de la
construction européenne he c'est le fil
rouge et c'est la colonne vertébrale qui
a permis l'agrégation de l'électorat
centriste de l'électorage jupéiste de
l'électorage troscanien il venaient de
la gauche il venaient de la droite mais
il partageaient cet idéal européen et
cette nécessité d'un agenda de réforme
et le deuxième élément qui coagule qui
peut coaguler ses forces c'est
l'inquiétude à la base de cet
électorat face à la perspective
justement d'une victoire des extrêmes et
donc il pourrait y avoir
euh une pression de ces ces ces
électeurs via les sondages via des
primaires sur les états-majors en leur
disant vous devez vous mettre d'accord
il ne faut qu'une tête sans quoi nous
serons éliminés dès le soir du du
premier tour al on va dire un mot de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous en parler c'est
un électorat archipel c'est ce que vous
dites et vous dites que le facteur
religieux joue un rôle important dans
ces scores selon une enquêtiope 69 % des
personnes de confession musulmanes ont
voté pour lui en 2022 c'était 37 % en
2017 est-ce que ça peut expliquer ses
prises de position dernièrement
notamment sur la guerre en Israël que
ses opposants ont taxé de clientélisme
électoral alors euh le score de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans l'électorat musulman est
tout à fait spectaculaire on a aucun
autre groupe social ou culturel dans
l'archipel qui a voté aussi massivement
aussi homogènement pour un candidat une
fois qu'on a dit ça l'électorat Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est loin de se réduire
uniquement à l'électorat musulman ou
l'électorat des cités il est en tête
dans toutes les grandes capitales
régionales par exemple à Bordeaux à
Toulouse euh à Nantes à Rennes et donc
on a un électorat de centr-eville et
dans la jeunesse aussi c'est ce que et
ben notamment celle-là jeunesse
étudiante et autres euh on l' aussi un
vote Mélenchon qui est important dans ce
qui reste de du mou ce qu'on appelait le
mouvement ouvrier organisé c'est-à-dire
les gens qui sont salariés et qui sont
syndiqué à la CGT à force Ouvrière donc
on n'est pas du tout ou pas forcément
dans un électorat musulmans néanmoins
euh Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses
lieutenants ont constaté les scores très
importants qu'ils avaient obtenu dans le
93 qu'ils avaient obtenu attrape plus de
60 % des voix dans l'électorat musulman
et ils ont aussi constaté la forte
abstention dans ces quartiers et en bon
marxiste il ils ont recyclé si vous
voulez la la thèse de l'armée de réserve
euh qu'il faut aller mobiliser
pour conquérir les voies qui ont manqué
pour la qualification au 2uxème tour et
c'est de mon point de vue ce qui
explique les prises de position très
singulières de la France insouvmise sur
le conflit israëlo-palestinien c'est
conforter cette base et aller chercher
un nouvel électorat qui est un électorat
abstentionniste en lui envoyant des
messages particulièrement ciblés toute
la question de savoir est-ce que cette
stratégie va être payante et est-ce que
c'est en s'exprimant de cette façon
qu'on va aller chercher des
abstentionnistes dans les quartier vous
parlez aussi dans ce livre de l'état de
la société notamment de la laïcité à
l'école en rappelant certains chiffres
29 % des enseignants s'autocensur dans
leur renseignement afin d'éviter les
réactions de certains élèves un
enseignant sur 5 dans le dans le public
et a été exposé un élève refusant doter
son vêtement religieux et vous rappelez
l'évolution de la laïcité à l'école
depuis l'affaire du voile de crille he
c'était en 89 vous dites 30 ans plus
tard la politique d'intégration n'a pas
produit les résultats escomptés et
l'affirmation religieuse et identitaire
musulmane a donné lieu à l'émergence au
plan vestimentaire d'un Muslim style
voilà donc c'est la la question de la BA
par exemple
euh il y a pas que la question et les
camises pour les pour les garçons il y a
pas que la question vestimentaire on
nous remonte euh
des des des difficultés ou des tensions
sur le contenu de certains enseignements
on a parlé tout à l'heure du conflit
Israël aupalestinien sur comment on
enseigne dans certains qu dans certains
établissements aujourd'hui le conflit
isralo-palestinien la Choa c'est
compliqué euh mais ça va au-delà dans
alors là c'est pour le collège et lycée
dans des dans des niveaux scolaires type
primaire aujourd'hui c'est des dans
certaines écoles de refus de cours de
chant parce que il est interdit de de
chanter euh c'est un peu plus
anciennement la question des menus
alimentaires dans dans les cantines et
donc on voit là aussi j'essaie de de
penser comment la société française
s'est transformée en profondeur comment
sur 40 ans on a une ce que j'ai appelé
une inversion de polarité sur la
question de la laïcité c'est-à-dire
qu'en
1984 c'est la grande manifestation pour
l'école privée ou l'enseignement libre
comme disaient les ses ses soutiens
contre le projet d'intégrer l'école
privé dans un système unifié d'école
publique 10 ans plus tard c'est la
contre manifestation la contre la loi
fallalou la réforme de la loi Fallou qui
là mobilise le camp laïque de gauche
contre des avant avantage qui serait
donné ou octroyé à l'école privée et
donc là en fait on s'en rend pas
forcément compte sur le moment mais on a
les derniers feux de ce qu'on a appelé
historiquement la guerre des deux écoles
he qui nous a occupé du début du 20e la
loi sur la licité 1905 l'école au public
obligatoire et cetera et cetera et donc
c'est les derniers feux de cette grande
histoire là où on avait un camp de
gauche qui défendait la laïcité
intransigente et un camp de droite
adossé à l'école catholique à l'église
catholique qui défendait la liberté euh
d'enseignement entre ces deux dates 84
et 94 il y a l'affaire de crille le
foulard de Cray en 1989 et en fait comme
en tectonique des plaques il y a une
plaque qui est en train de de décliner
une autre qui se surpose superpose
dessus c'est la l'émergence de euh
l'affirmation identitaire religieuse
musulmane à l'école qui va énormément
revitaliser la question de la laïcité
avec la loi de de 2004 et aujourd'hui là
encore on a des têtes à queue
spectaculaires en 1984 Jean-Marie Le Pen
défile à Versailles dans le cortège
défendant l'enseignement privé et 30 ans
plus tard ou 40 ans plus tard c'est sa
fille qui se drape ou qui se dépint
comme étant la plus ardente défenseuse
d'une laïcité à la française dans le
service public mais cette fois non plus
contre l'influence de l'Église
catholique mais d'un islam d'un islam
qui progresse c'est ce que vous dites
elle elle a elle s'ériige aujourd'hui en
rempart d'une laïcité menacée dans
l'enceinte de l'école républicaine par
le fondamentalisme islamique un mot sur
un sujet dont vous parlez aussi c'est le
développement du trafic de stupéfiant du
trafic de drogue dans le pays ces 20
dernières années vous donnez SIIF il y a
aujourd'hui 4000 points deal dans le
pays qui sont illégaux et 24000 bureaux
de tabac on est dans un rapport de 1 à 6
entre ce qui est légal et ce qui est
illégal quelles conséquen sur la société
le développement de ce trafic de drogue
en quoi c'est un facteur de
déstabilisation comme vous dit et bien
c'est gigantesque parce qu'en fait c'est
4000 points de Deal alors les chiffres
varient parce que certains sont
démantelés ils se recréent un peu plus
loin aussitôt ailleurs euh le
développement de C ce trafic en fait
c'est métastasé dans tout le territoire
national c'est plus uniquement les
quartiers nord de Marseille ou les cités
difficile de la région parisienne ou de
la banlieu lyonnaise c'est partout en
France la le moindre la moindre
sous-préfecture a son quartier sensible
avec son point de Deal le quartier de la
monnaie à roman on en a parlé tout à
l'heure et bien la l'activité délincante
que j'évoquais elle se structure autour
du trafic de stupéfiant et donc ça
déstabilise des quartiers entiers ça
entretient dans une activité délinquante
des milliers des milliers d'individus on
estime que 200000 personnes vivent du
trafic de drogue en France donc c'est le
la l'interpro du chit en fait et bien
elle salarie plus de monde que la SNCF
en France et dans cette vous dites il y
a plus de point plus de points deil que
de McDo en France voilà tout à fait he
1600 restaurants McDonald's et donc euh
cette vénérable maison le Sénat a
auditionné dans une commission d'enquête
cette semaine des responsables policiers
qui ont parlé d'un trafic qui était
devenu hors de contrôle donc non
seulement ça déstabilise des quartiers
et ça entretient une activité
délinquante mais ça génère des flux
financiers colossaux qui ensuite
repartent dans des activités de
corruption un dernier mot gérum Fourquet
puisque vous parlez également de la
disparition des services publics c'était
un des carburants des gilets jaunes dont
on a fêté les C d'existence en novembre
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le mouvement peut
revenir alors pas sans dout l'histoire
repasse pas les plats donc sans doute
pas sous cette forme là mais les
ingrédients sont toujours là
rappelez-vous quand le mouvement démarre
novembre 2018 le litre de gasoile est à
1 €40 1,40 € on est aujourd'hui près des
2 €
euh la volonté de d'être davantage
écouté par cette France invisible est
toujours là et par rapport à 2018 c'est
surjouté le retour de de l'inflation
notamment sur les produits alimentaires
qui ont augmenté de 20 % en 2 ans et une
enquête récente de l'Ifop pour la la
Fondation jean-joress a montré que 40 %
de nos concitoyens avaient réduit pour
des raisons financières la taille des
portions alimentaires qui étaient
servies à la maison donc les ingrédients
sont là euh là où les choses ont sans
doute un peu changé c'est que le
gouvernement en est conscient de cette
situation hautement inflammable et c'est
notamment cette prise de conscience qui
à mon avis explique le fait que après
quelques jours de tergiversation
on est renouvelé sur toute l'année 2024
par exemple la possibilité d'acheter des
produits alimentaires non transformés
via les les fameux CK restaurants pour
essayer de faire baisser la température
et et la pression sociale merci Jérôme
merci beaucoupationci pour pour cet
entretien et pour ce livre passionnant
pour comprendre la France aujourd'hui la
France d'après tabo politique c'est aux
éditions du Seuil merci beaucoup pour on
passe au club des territoires